uh what's this tom cruise thing oh he
flips his [ __ ]
can we listen oh yeah this is
stoked so this is on you linked
a website this so this is what is this
this website that you linked
um it seems like oh reddit
um yeah it's like uh it's like the
comments section of live leak
but just as a website oh okay that's
kind of cool yeah okay
this is tom cruise on the set of mission
impossible seven
we're in hollywood making movies right
now because of us
because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every studio at
night
insurance companies producers
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] i love that top comment les
grossman is back baby
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone
like timber he's got in his voice you
know he's just accessing the
back part of his throat man ever
[Laughter]
did you ever do anything [ __ ] do it
again
do we need that [ __ ] i was like
oh [ __ ]
yeah so funny that he said it right
after like
basically we're doing a good thing we're
creating thousands of jobs you
[ __ ] you're
fired
we're creating jobs we're giving people
their livelihoods back by the way you're
fired
[ __ ] you dude when he is and you and you
and you i like the picture it's only
those f
like four people in the room four or
five people in the room and you
and you and you don't you ever [ __ ]
do it again
that's it nope that's not it
pause that's the that's the greatest
twist of this whole thing
is we we know the future and that is not
it that's not it we still got it we're
about halfway through when he said
that's it the whole room was like okay
oh my god oh no you got another minute
at least
the censor beat makes this so much
funnier dude
[Laughter]
shut down it's not going to put food on
their table
or pay for their college education
college
damn this guy's education
or their barbecue
we're buying their [ __ ] barbecue who
do you think pays for this barbecue
craft services
me i bought the [ __ ] place
that's what i sleep with every night
damn dude you got a lot of riding on you
crazy that mission impossible seven
holds the keys to the future of the
entire
[ __ ] film industry to be honest it
wouldn't surprise me
just by the sheer amount of people it
probably takes to make that [ __ ]
movie
yeah i bet there's like a key grip on
there who's like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i need this so bad yeah that's true
that's true
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you and now i want it and if
you don't do it you're
out
we are not shutting this movie down oh
my god
holy [ __ ] he just reached an entire new
level there
yeah yeah
is it understood if i see it again
you're
going i don't think i get it yet tom
tom over actually i was just saying if i
see it again you're [ __ ] gone
dude understood it's so funny to think
about him wanting
to get in their faces but he has to stay
six feet away
yeah so he's just six feet away like
leaning in
he's pushing the edge like his nose is
coming over that
invisible that invisible inch yeah he's
pushing into that force field
yeah whatever
he sees what you see in the oculus yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah just said like literally
it's just a little grid force field yeah
if i could i'd be in your fight in your
[ __ ] face right now
you'd smell my cornbread breath from
craft services that i paid for
because i carry the whole way to this
industry who do you think
is keeping the barbecue industry alive
right now who do you think you
are i am so you're gonna cost him his
job
and i see it on the set you're going and
you're going
that's it am i clear do you
understand what i want you understand
the responsibility that you have
yes tom you're fired [ __ ] you
i will deal with your reason and if you
can't be reasonable
and i can't deal with your legend you're
fired
that's it that is it
what i trust you guys to be here
damn i mean i get it is he
is he the director i i wonder if he
maybe he's like an executive producer so
maybe he
or maybe maybe it's just like a key
element in getting money for these
movies
it sounds like he's the head honcho
also so funny screaming like [ __ ]
particles are just spraying through his
mask
[Music]
he's got a point right bro can you
imagine how upset you would be if you
had
if they're maybe even in a foreign
country or just somewhere they went
through so many
hoops and paid all that money
to get all that [ __ ] there just for
someone to get coronavirus and they have
to
kill the whole thing oh yeah i can't
even imagine how much money it costs to
put that production on hold for like
even a week it's probably like
10 million dollars bro
the and it kind of is true because
you know for the next year hollywood is
going to use this as the model
to fund movies at this caliber and so if
this one gets shut down they lose money
on it then there's
not gonna be another one and [ __ ]
what would what would we do without
mission impossible you know what i'm
saying
i mean yeah the whole the whole movie
industry would collapse
i'm just saying what would we do without
another mission impossible specifically
i mean to be honest mission impossible
is probably the only other franchise
that releases now
outside of avengers yeah and
superheroes and double seven yeah
one in fast and furious was uh yeah
yeah all this yeah but you know never as
good as the first just have to throw
that out there yeah
one of nema's buddies produced a pretty
big music video and he was saying that
coronavirus safety stuff he said it eats
up so much money
and the third parties that
are sort of responsible for that it's
just you know
or i don't in so many words like what i
gathered from what he said was basically
that
these companies can kind of charge
whatever they want
and and it's and i guess it's a theme
that when the budget's big
companies not necessarily people doing
chronovirus testing but
will just charge more because they know
there's money there which is so
[ __ ] yeah and but yeah he said
it's it's wild how how much the
chronovirus protocol stuff
eats into the money before you even get
to
getting the stuff you need to make it so
i can only imagine a movie of this scale
it's probably just huge money
and what is budget and what do you think
what do you think happened here
someone's just walking around without
their mask
i would think that like a group of dudes
probably just went out
i would think they're just in like some
random city and they're like oh dude
let's just
we're just here we're not doing [ __ ] we
don't work till monday
yeah just go out dude i'm sick let's
just go [ __ ] a local
yeah let's just go [ __ ] a local guys i'm
terribly sorry to let you know i will
not be participating in next week's race
um because um i've gotten my dick sucked
by
yeah last week i got sucked off by a
local
and um i mean she really sucked that
this
all out of my body she came out
like a banshee just like absolute
monster
sucked me off tom cruise you guys want
to go get sucked off
huh the whole feature of the mu the
movie industry is resting in our hands
and you're going to go get sucked off by
a local
that's what i sleep with every night
you guys getting sucked off by a local
how dare you
our boy man our boy was ninja man
yeah seriously that was ninja level tilt
bro yeah yeah yeah
it's out there it's not just a movie
it's not people say it's just a movie
it's tom is just mission impossible
it's not just mr impossible this is the
fil
the future of the film industry
and you guys are getting if you say it's
just a movie
literally kill yourselves
it's like ninja toxic if you think this
is just a movie
literally kill yourselves you are the
worst person
in the entire planet if it's just a
movie to you
then why are you making it every time
you go to make a movie it should be
mind bending
it's a mind-bending experience that
you're trying to provide
yeah you should be competitive about it
you should be trying to make the
greatest movie on earth every single
time every single time and if you
don't and you should kill yourself you
should definitely get rid of yourself
get rid of your life
get rid yourself from this earth
[ __ ]
i'm just struggling to remember the
exact thing ninja said about
you know when people are like it's just
a game yeah probably that was probably
pretty close
you